então vamos lá o tema da minha palestra
o poder de dar a volta por cima
eu criei uma metodologia que chama
turnaround que é a arte de virar o jogo
mas porque que dar a volta por cima
porque virar o jogo
eu ao longo de 23 anos de
empreendedorismo ao longo de 31 anos de
trabalho e com meus 10 anos de
experiência internacional eu entendi que
o ser humano seja no brasil ou no japão
ou em qualquer parte do planeta ele é
eterno insatisfeito ele sempre quer
viver em outro patamar
ele quer ter uma vida melhor se um carro
uma casa ganhar mais dinheiro mudar de
profissão mudar de vida viajar pelo
mundo nós somos eternos insatisfeito em
tão independente da sua situação
financeira a sua situação é profissional
nós podemos virar o jogo a todo momento
e sempre dar a volta por cima e isso
significa que não é pra mostrar para o
meu vizinho pra minha família pra
ninguém e se meu poder de raven tentar o
meu poder diz viver em outro patamar
existe uma filosofia no japão que fala a
filosofia kaizen doeu melhor a cada dia
hoje ser melhor do que ontem e amanhã
ser melhor do que hoje
então nós devemos e e e temos que correr
atrás
atrás dessa evolução contínua dessa
evolução permanente mas minha vida não
começa hoje sou empresário empresa está
presente em doze estados mais de 40
cidades mas minha vida nem sempre foi
assim
se eu nasci numa família muito pobre que
é diferente de humildade e morei numa
casa de barro até meus 19 anos de idade
eu fui conhecer meu pai com 18 anos de
idade e com nove anos de idade eu tive o
meu primeiro tornou onde que foi a minha
primeira virada
minha mãe acordava às 5 horas da manhã e
ia para a roça e ela voltava entre sete
e oito horas da noite e naquele dia me
recordo muito bem como se fosse o dia de
hoje
ela colocou um prato de feijão na mesa e
ela empurrou o prato falando com
o meu filho que esse feijão está gostoso
naquele momento uma criança de 9 anos de
idade só estava eu e ela eu falei mãe
vamos comer junto ela empurrou pra tudo
de novo na minha frente e começou a
chorar
naquele momento com nove anos de idade
eu entendi que não era a falta de forma
entende que uma mãe ela quando ela tem
filhos para sustentar
ela prefere dar comida aos filhos o que
ela mesmo comer uma criança de 9 anos de
idade que é brincar que estudar ela não
pensa em fazer nada mais fora desse
contexto mesmo porque ela não tem muito
discernimento de saber o que fazer com
nove anos de idade e naquele momento eu
tomei uma decisão que eu precisava virar
o jogo da minha vida
até meus quatro anos de idade a gente
não tinha água nem energia potável
minha mãe é buscar água na bica que
estava no fogão de lenha e dava banho e
quatro crianças numa bacia em uma bacia
de alumínio
então eu cresci com aquele mapa mental
de uma forma muito bem estruturada que
eu não podia mudar a minha origem
mas eu podia fazer do meu destino
destino diferente da minha vida então
como nove anos de idade eu saí pedir
emprego
bati na porta de uma vizinha ela é deu a
oportunidade de eu pegar leite
andei andava dois quilômetros para em
dois quilômetros para votar
toda vez que eu entregava o leite ela me
dava uma moedinha e essa moedinha
conseguia comprar pão conseguia comprar
feijão conseguia comprar algum tipo de
alimento para levar em casa mas pelo
pouco tempo que eu tenho aqui eu não
quero falar muito da minha história eu
só quero começar com um único
pressuposto em nossa vida que nós temos
que parar de usar muletas e justificar o
porquê que eu não estou conseguindo mais
na minha vida
aí eu não consigo mais porque eu não
tive faculdade assim como eu eu não
consigo mais porque eu nasci numa
família pobre se como eu eu não consigo
mais porque eu nasci numa cidade de 13
mil habitantes assim como eu
só que todas essas muletas que são
impeditivos mentais
não não fizeram de mim um cara que era
o o o cara da vítima o vitimismo que
hoje está muito na moda o governo está
ruim
o país é ruim a política não muda a
cidade que eu nasci não pode oferecer
nada e aí fica passando o tempo e tempo
ea gente não consegue sair do lugar
baseado nisso eu criei uma metodologia
que a minha empresa é responsável por
recuperar empresas quebradas do setor
imobiliário
então nós usamos esses três pilares e
foram os três pilares que usei na minha
vida pra mudar também a minha vida o meu
destino eu quebrei seis vezes
estou no meu 13º negócio ea última
quebra foi de uma dívida de mais de 3
mil e 3 milhões de reais
quando você se vê num buraco que é um
buraco tão fundo que você nunca esteve
nesse buraco você entende que talvez não
tenha mais nenhuma solução e aí eu
lembrei desse método que fala como
agente expandir a nossa mentalidade como
a gente mudar o nosso comportamento e
como adquirir as novas competências
porque em cada momento que eu que brava
em cada momento que eu fracassava me
faltava uma competência e o que a gente
tem que entender que faz parte dessa
jornada
quando você erra quando você fracassa
quando você perde é um mercado que está
falando alguma coisa pra você
mas nós estamos acostumados a não
aceitar feedback nós
justificamos o nosso fracasso o nosso
erro ea nossa falha e colocar essa
responsabilidade que é de nossa
competência na mão de outras pessoas
e aí eu não consigo mudar uma vez que eu
não enxergo que o erro é meu e todas as
vezes que eu quebrei eu entendia que o
único culpado era eu e que naquele
momento eu estava ser do falho que não
tinha competência suficiente
e aí eu fui aplicar a metodologia que o
meu primeiro pilar meu primeiro
princípio é não queira resultados
imediatos
não existe bala de prata não existe
fórmula mágica quem vende isso na minha
opinião é batedor de carteira
eu levei 23 anos para ser bem sucedido
da noite para o dia 23 anos eu comecei
empreender desde os meus 17 anos
então a gente tem que parar de achar que
é esse negócio no próximo negócio que
vai mudar a minha vida aí eu fico seis
meses aqui do outro lugar ficou mais
seis meses lá vou para outro lugar e não
consigo parar nada a gente tem que parar
de ser um phd em começar ativa e começar
a ser um phd em acaba ativa
comece uma coisa e vai até o final você
vai ver a magia desse resultado seja
inconformado tem uma música dos louros
tons que ele falou eu não consigo ficar
satisfeito por inteiro
bom não é bom ou ótimo esperado a gente
se contenta com muito pouco
aí eu estou ganhando isso tá pra pagar
conta tá bom
aí eu conseguisse um emprego mas esse
emprego não era o que eu queria mas está
bom
aí eu estou ganhando esse dinheiro tem
uma empresa eu estou crescendo a cada
dez anos a cada cinco anos mas tá bom
e aí eu fico me contentando com um bom e
esse contentamento da baseado muito nas
minhas referências né
se você não tem um outro mundo de
experimentação você sempre vai achar que
aquilo que você tem é o suficiente que
aquilo que você está conseguindo naquele
momento é o máximo que você consegue
e aí você entende que existe um livro
que chama de lisbo qui que ele consegue
mostrar pra mim pra vocês que tanto eu
como vocês podem quebrar recordes
você vai quebrar seu próprio recorde ou
vai ver alguém vai quebrar o recorde de
alguém então por que não mais por que
não viver em contentamento tempo tudo
ninguém está falando de perfeccionismo
ninguém está falando
de ingratidão nós estamos falando para
que o esteja em movimento tempo todo
faça o que tem que ser feito
as pessoas querem falar hoje fala muito
a palavra da moda ruptura aí eu preciso
ser disruptivo mas aí você entra na
empresa era consultor de empresa eu
entrava na empresa e ele não fazia
nenhuma rosto com feijão bem feito
ele não consegue atender bem feito ele
não consegue dar feedback de seu cliente
ele não consegue chegar no horário no
japão eles se programa para chegar meia
hora antes de qualquer encontro aqui o
brasileiro e chega meia hora depois ele
não justificou o atraso
então a gente tem que tomar cuidado de
tentar falar 'não eu preciso inovação é
importante quando você já fez
o arroz com feijão bem feito foco você
pode ter 300 planos bes
mas para atingir o plano a senão você
vai ser o pato que nada corre você não
faz nada bem
você quer seu ou aquele cara polivalente
bacana mas qualquer sua especialidade
qual é sua melhor especialidade que é
percebido pelos outros não percebido
pelos por você
às vezes as pessoas falam nossa eu sou
bom em vendas
esses dias eu recebi uma proposta do
instagram como aumentar o número de
seguidores ele tinha 1.800 seguidores
eu estava com 130 mil foi acho que é o
que tem que ser lá né então por não é na
coerente então primeiro para que eu seja
percebido como especialista houve venda
como especialista de fato tem que ser
porque senão não fecha conta as pessoas
geram a credibilidade tem atitude
tem muita gente eu tenho usa esses três
pilares que eu gosto muito que é o
sonhar tem gente que sonha há pouco o
sonho é pequeno demais
a que você quer se eu sair do aluguel tá
bom mas por que tão pouco o sair do
aluguel pode ser uma fase inicial hoje
você tem que pensar grande tem que ter
um sonho
gigante e aí tem pessoas que não treinam
ele sonha mas no treino eu aprendi em
toda a minha vida que eu preferia sua
dentro de do treino do que sangrar em
campo porque quando você abre uma
empresa quebra quando você não está
ganhando dinheiro quando você não
consegue arrumar um emprego quando você
não consegue realizar seus sonhos suas
metas e seus objetivos você está
sangrando o tempo todo e aí tem gente
que treina treina treina mas não joga
tem pessoas que fazem 300 cursos têm
pessoas que lhes 50 livros mas não entre
em campo jogar nenhum mestre de cozinha
nem um bom cozinheiro fica sendo bom
cozinheiro apenas lendo receita
ele lê a receita mas ele prática ele vai
aperfeiçoando a sua receita
então é muito importante sonhar grande
treinar bastante e agir entrar em campo
vamos jogar se afaste de perdedores
mentais esses caras são sugadores de
energia
tem pessoas que só consegue chegar a
metade do copo vazio
tem pessoas que não conseguem enxergar o
lado bom das coisas
como estava chovendo eu vou dar uma
palestra a mas é uma outra cidade eu vou
hamas tem que ler mas tem que pôr sempre
é um problema para essa pessoa e não
quer sair da zona de conforto do que é
sair do lugar
a minha pergunta é você está disposto a
fazer o fácil difícil
tem uma frase que eu gosto muito que
fala se você tiver disposto a fazer o
difícil provavelmente você terá uma vida
fácil agora se você estiver disposto a
fazer sol fácil provavelmente você terá
uma vida difícil
eu estou há 19 anos trabalhando 12 horas
por dia seis dias por semana e não paro
porque trabalho pra mim não é uma
sofrença trabalho pra mim é um prazer é
uma brincadeira eu amo porque com nove
anos de idade eu tive que trocar a minha
brincadeira por um trabalho persistência
não basta bater na porta
mas bata até abrir tem gente que existe
muito fácil do seu sonho
quantos não nos cabe no se o seu sim de
repente é seu grande sonho
resiliência já foi falado é na
diversidade que alguns desistem e outros
batem recorde
quando eu entrei na academia eu escutava
muito uma frase no pay no gay sem dor
sem ganho não existe vitória sem dor e
tá tudo bem porque todo mundo vai passar
por essa jornada não existe bala de
prata não existe fórmula mágica não
existe sucesso tão fácil como se vende
lá fora essa é a outra face do sucesso
agora é possível quando você chega lá
você vai agradecer porque poucos
consegue cruzar a linha de chegada
poucos qual foi a última vez que você
fez algo pela primeira vez saia da zona
de conforto saia do seu quadrado tenha
brilho nos olhos
tem gente que fala em vencer na vida
como se fosse a eu quero vencer
se está vibrando qual intensidade qual é
a vontade que você tem
se você pegar todos os livros de de
décadas atrás fala que é que o vencedor
ele tem muita paixão pela vitória pela
conquista é só você pegar o ayrton senna
e pegar outros atletas de alta
performance entender qualquer vontade
que esse cara tem de entrar em campo e
ganhar
ele não entra para brigar pra a se
ganhar ganhou não entra para ganhar
a gente tem que começar a entrar em
campo para ganhar
quando perder a aposta não perca a lição
não se preocupa com muitas vezes você
errou na sua vida é no fundo do poço que
nós encontramos grandes diamantes
as cicatrizes da vida é bela
a diferença de uma pessoa de sucesso é
que ela fracassou muito mais vezes que o
indivíduo sem sucesso tentou então tenta
tente tente outra vez e mais contas
forem necessário
continue tentando
até você conseguir não desista as suas
escolhas
nós já falamos tem gente que achar um
livro de quarenta reais mas sai daqui e
vai beber meia dúzia de cerveja e no
outro dia tá ferrado do mesmo jeito você
está escolhendo fomentar o que nada
nessa vida é permanente um dia no chão
um dia de pé
não existe gráfico reto e acredite você
é melhor do que isso você pode eu tinha
todos os indicadores para ser uma pessoa
sem sucesso todos todos os indicadores e
eu venci
você também pode meu livro ele tem todos
os princípios ele fala do poder de dar a
volta por cima que foi uma grande
realização e eu tô aqui
finalizando falando que a nossa maior
fraqueza tá em desistir
se você tiver que desistir que desista
de desistir desistir jamais
essa é a única alternativa que você não
pode deixar que isso incorporem na sua
vida eu quero terminar com uma frase
falando que um homem e uma mulher de
moral nunca fica no chão e reconhece a
queda e não desanima levanta sacode a
poeira e dá a volta por cima
meu muito obrigado
[Aplausos]